good morning Millennials we are back and
we are so excited to be sitting down
with a personal hero and someone
frequently discussed on this show
Daymond John welcome thank you welcome
to the toast we know you're used to the
tank but it's the chest thank you got it
you are here you have a new book your
third book is coming out next Tuesday
well this is actually my the time I
don't really have the time but this is
my I think this is my third in five
years which is that's why how most
people know these New York Times
bestseller already why for that
three-piece
the only shark to ever do that would
only even become a New York Times
bestseller so true yes eavers don't all
the time but I mean it's a challenge me
rubbing down the face because I'm the
youngest I'm the smartest I have the
number one investment on the show I have
the New York Times I sell I have more
followers and almost all on besides Mark
Cuban so sorry I've got a lot of things
who really is the number one investment
on the show they're referring to
Amba socks use Cotto stepmama socks all
right I had no clue that was a number
one investment of the tank number one
invested in so the number one show the
number one product that came on the tank
that didn't get an investment is yeah
that's crazy how some of those products
even like plated right now they had a
deal that fell through and then heaven
go up to heaven and now they're big do
you think like before you let your head
at night do you think about all the
deals like that you wish you did or that
you would you have any regrets when it
comes to the shark tank no not really um
but I only I only realized that after a
period of time because you know like
Lori will invest as someone as stupid as
[ __ ] I've ever seen what it will
actually work because she knows her
customers yeah you know and I don't so
it really is the right shark with the
right product the right person with the
right vision all combined
it's so true do you ever see an episode
that you weren't on with in the
inventors who come in and you're like oh
I wish I was there for that no I don't
look at that ones I'm not
yeah just they're not interested I also
don't look at them up I'll tell you why
cuz honestly I'm a fan of the show
so I'll get caught up and I'll end up
calling somebody like Kevin hey can I
get in on that and I then I realized I
get buyer's remorse I realized live in
it I can barely keep up with what I have
yeah let me just chill right so
logistically how do you deal with all of
the deals that you make on the show do
you have like a part of your team that
works with a charger so we have a really
great team that works with all the
entrepreneurs and we sort them so if you
look at about 80 investments you look at
probably 30 of them are over the period
of time they're really not doing that
well so why call them and bother them
another 30 I'm like you know some of the
great companies they only call me when
they really need me but they're really
great operators right and so now then we
focus in on the 30 the 30 percent that
could move to either lane yeah
so has your experience with those
entrepreneurs influence the deals you
now make going forward like do you see
something in someone that would either
make you want to make a deal with them
absolutely but we keep learning I mean
that's a that's the reality of it I've
seen deals that I've said wow this is
like its own songs like going on a first
date it's perfect everything that looks
right and then all of a sudden you know
there's thinking that's always how it
happens yeah or you date the more you
realize what you're looking for exactly
and so some we see that we're not doing
I needed to know more people or need
more information that's why one invest
in this person because they bring value
to me to learn how to do other
investments right so with the book
you're talking to a lot of legitimate
people you got Mark Cuban in here
Lindsey Vonn and one of our personal
favorite guest sharks Bethenny Franco
Bethenny of course and we love her
friendship with like all the sharks it's
so cute and kris Jenner's in the book
personal hero my hero of our generation
I would say um can you talk to me a
little bit about your relationship with
Kris Jenner how you got her to open up
in the book and how do you know her even
well actually when they first call me
for shark tank I turned it down because
I was doing a lot of the management and
a lot of the product integration in the
Kardashians so I was I was handling the
girls and how they were going to be
perceived you know and I walked them all
around the Hatton and I remember a big
big company that
I'm not gonna say the name but really a
big coming that I know I said these
girls will wear your jeans for all three
of the girls will know actually would
increase their wear your jeans for the
entire season for seventy-five dollars
seventy five thousand dollars and they
all said no these girls will never make
it Wow so if you notice the first two
years of the show they're all wearing
coogee one of my brand's because I said
girls I'm sorry I couldn't get other
people to support you so I'm gonna give
you the money and then Chris would uh
you know pick my brain once in a while
but then she would go off and really her
and Kim and them they would really do
what I was doing you know four years in
FUBU on videos they would learn how to
do that in a whole new space I was
coming around call Instagram and social
media and they would take it to Heights
that I never had taken a to in my
personal career and so we had a really
great working relationship and I
remember when I used to be at the house
when I was first starting with them and
Kendall and Kylie they were running
around in their little onesie pajamas or
hiding underneath the table and I was
trying to peek in the meetings and
fighting each other and they was they
must have been ten years old at the time
and and so then I decided once I was
reading this book about how people need
to understand how to control power and
and and and and understand what they
need to do their lives as simple changes
let me go to ten or twelve other people
that also know this formula but I'm
giving the people that executed a whole
different way so I decided to go to Kris
and she said absolutely I'm gonna lay
out you know my blueprint to how I
created power with with you know my
girls and my family do you think she
would be a good guest shark on the tank
absolutely her deal was probably more
than the Sharks I mean if you think
about her running about six or seven
towel and globally recognized talent
yeah and how many calls are coming in
from live speaking game to Twitter to
tweet excuse me to products yes yeah and
she their businesses too so I feel like
she really runs the gamut we could get
her in the tank and their successful
business if you really think oh yeah
Carly Cosmetics skims now good American
she's wearing her own jeans now yeah
rifle circle full circle so what is what
does it mean to power shift so so many
people you know after the first two
books and
was really challenging writing the you
know any book because I'm Dyslexic right
and I kept trying to give all this
information out to people who felt that
they either did not have power in their
life somebody took away power from them
or somebody was in the way of it right
so many people saw I asked how can I
make these small changes in my life to
become successful and I just said let me
put it all in the book all the things
that I know that I was able to do I was
able to transform from fashion to they
know listened to being a motivational
speaker and an author and an investor
then on Shark Tank and it was so hard
and each one of those lanes is you know
growing in barriers differently it's so
hard to even get a foot in the door one
so what did I do when all these so what
did what did Kris Jenner doing all these
what did Bethenny doing all these ways
to be able to transform Bethenny from
you know reality star to owning her own
global brand to now being a producer and
leaving the show at the top of the game
right there's a you have to have a lot
of guts so somebody right here listening
who wants to leave a job or wants to
take a job wants to start their own
company start their own podcast get
fired from a job and say screw that I'm
going to control the power I wanted to
give people like a real step-by-step
blueprint on how to do that and it
doesn't start with just negotiating at
the table it's also building influence
it starts with it then you negotiate and
then you nurture the relationship to get
so much more out of it Wow I'm tweet we
got a lot of questions from Instagram a
lot about Shark Tank this is from
Letitia SR who do you consider your
biggest competition between all the
Sharks and who do you prefer to do deals
with like sometimes they'll suggest
going in and you say no what's the
mentality behind that yeah so the one of
the person who is my biggest competition
is Lori we're both in consumer packaged
goods meaning you know we take Goods and
we put them over the counter but also
she knows how to play the woman angle
right she knows how to say well if you
also come and work with me you're going
to naturally be you're gonna get two and
three hits because now you're gonna go
on QVC and let's say you walk in the
room and you your parents love QVC now
all of a sudden I have to fight against
you know your love and affection for
this other product your other platform
as well and Lori acts so cute
crap like mrs. what does she swear shark
with a heart credit every place so she's
my biggest competition but the ones are
the ones I love to do the deals with it
only depends on if they add more value
and we can add value to each other if
it's a tech deal I love to do a with
Robert or maybe Cuban if it's a royalty
or finance deal it's it's Kevin if it's
if it's something in these marketing
mm-hmm from and you need a genius
marketer it's Barbara she's probably the
best marketer I've seen in my life so so
you know it all depends on who it is so
it doesn't have anything to do with like
personal relationships more so like who
brings what to the team I equally love
and hate right it's like hard to tell
when you guys are joking yeah you guys
give each other a hard time
oh no we're like a family yeah we really
are like a family and but we also just
like a family
we're disgusted by each other right and
you're moving back to Friday nights we
are we're Friday nights 8 o'clock and
this is purely because the viewers had
said listen you know it's one of the
shop shows watch kids and parents
together my kids can't watch the show 10
o'clock at night on a Sunday they go to
school yes and other business people
have said I want to come in I want to
DVR'd and watch over the weekend yeah by
Sunday night my mind's already racing
about all the [ __ ] I got to do money to
they went I don't have time to so they
all wrote in and and and social media
embarrassing and they got the network to
move it - Wow never heard of that like
me no but listen the network listens to
nobody they we've been telling him for
years they totally ignored us but it was
a lot of Millennials also Gen Z people
who wrote in who said listen if you
don't do this I'm not watching it yeah
it's a great time to be on I like having
it on Friday nights much better yeah we
really appreciate it yeah okay yeah from
Margaret Brian what was your first job
and what was the best advice you
received in your career my first real
job will my for my first job my first
job was handing out flyers when I was a
kid like $2 25 cents per hour
I don't remember my then I was running
BX cable up in the Bronx and old
abandoned buildings and I was working at
churches fried chicken and I worked at a
popcorn stand I don't really remember
the first one though because it was it
all like at the same time yeah I was a
foot messenger out here in Manhattan
well the best advice I ever received
money is a great sleigh
but a horrible master and no matter how
much you're making right now
pay yourself first put away the money
because it compounds over the period of
time but the most important thing is to
get financial intelligence to learn
exactly just how money works yeah yeah
well we have a great question because
some one named Alice would love to hear
your advice on the best ways to start
investing your money in your 20s what
are simple effective steps to take
beginner's advice for newbie investors
sure so first of all you know I don't
want to say the old cliche but investing
yourself in an education whatever
category you want to go into but the
market is a really great place to invest
in but go to things that you really like
you understand you know Warren Buffett
says he'll never invest anything he
doesn't understand I I technically only
invest in things that if they went away
it would change my life so if Instagram
went away it would change my life if
over went away of Amazon in a way it
would change my life so try to find
things that would change your life and
educate yourself when it gets some
software some really cheap software
where you do not put any money in and
you play with the investments that you
like and hypothetically you would see
what you would have earned if you have
had $10 $100
$2,000 in it but don't go out and
necessarily invest besides your
education don't invest in anything else
out there like somebody else's company
because why don't you just invest in
other brilliant people like Elon Musk
and he's not gonna call you they ask you
for any money or I ask you for any
advice right yeah it's gonna open the
mailbox and is either gonna be money
there or not right so you'll save time
you'll you'll maximize the the talent of
other people and you'll have a good time
I have a question for you because you
spend a lot of time in New York you take
a lot of elevator rides your the
meetings business press and how many
times a day are you in an elevator and
someone pitches you you know probably
about I probably get pitched about two
times in a elevator but I get pictures
about I would say thirty times on the
street and and several hundred on social
media and various other things do you
take it seriously no no well that makes
us happy because we like I have always
said if we were ever in an elevator with
a shark we have our elevator pitch and
lo and behold we found ourselves in an
elevator with you one in the Bahamas two
years ago a year and a half
and we may start time we were you know
at the pool we had a couple drags and we
were just like in no shape to be making
it remember you guys so we were all
wearing white or something like that
party
I do remember guys were like they
drinking hard so we like picked our
heads up after you got out of the
elevator and we're like to be just make
a mistake but I'm really good I don't
know that we did here's how here's our
elevator pitch close and I actually put
it in the book because the 90 seconds
that you're gonna be an elevator with
somebody you won't know that you would
ever see them alright but there's a
small pitch you do and what happens is
you know this book is about building
influence how do you build influence in
90 seconds you don't tell me a little
something about it you leave and then I
go look you up right that's what
happened with us whether you knew that I
was looking you up or not
because somebody else told me about you
and when we were in elevator and I said
what are you talking about and then we
went over around the you know the corner
and you guys were raving it was it was
it was it was real to your brand
yes exactly Arion brand for us to be
drinking in the Bahamas right so when
when we got the call that that we could
potentially do something you would
already created influence with me a lot
of people think influencer needs to be
know be true to your brand I'm a big fan
of old dirty bastard he was an old dirty
bastard and that's exactly what I wanted
from him yeah and so when we saw you
guys raving and all-white all in the
corner and I was like honey I did call
the police on you call the police on you
but I was still very very very impressed
how do you find that like in the age of
social media people are being more or
less authentic to whatever brand they're
trying to create I do think that people
are being more believe it or not I think
there are a lot of people you know with
impostor syndrome and they're acting a
certain way and they're not getting
anywhere but I think that the ones are
seeing the success room while the people
who were just true to their brands
really and you know it's it's I think is
refreshing in some sense but I think the
the ones who are playing the imposter
syndrome they drown out they create this
distrust distress some people on the
internet have a way
like sniffing you out if you're being
fake you cannot lie on the internet
absolutely I've tried from muskie
if you could pick three companies to sit
on the board of which three would they
be there would be Tesla Apple and it
would have to be somebody else changing
the world in a good way
saving the planet I would have to think
about a company doing that Oh
there wouldn't be chain world good way
maybe but I'll be learning more from
Bezos so the Amazon yeah I love that I
love I love global thinking people think
people are thinking so far you know
someone like a Jeff Bezos they think
still like an entrepreneur even like a
scrappy startup yeah you start telling
people listen at work you can start
taking boxes home and we'll save one our
you know our mailing fees I also have a
trusted employee taking it home so I
know what's gonna happen and you'll make
extra money I mean that's thinking like
an entrepreneur yeah they're truly
taking over the world who's someone that
would be like a dream guest shark on
Shark Tank like a Jeff Bezos sorry yeah
of course you have basis but let's try
to think of some other ones that are
really who's less busy yeah I mean Chris
I'm Chris Jenner absolutely and she's a
great just TV personality yeah she's a
circle I love her and so many people
look up to her I feel like maybe outside
of the typical Shark Tank viewer if you
from Elise Cebu if you could get
business advice from one person dead or
alive who would it be
[Music]
Thomas Edison you think who else dead or
alive business advice from dead alive I
don't know maybe Gandhi yeah if you can
change the world
you know in your underwear think outside
the box a little bit do you watch a lot
of TV I do not I don't have time yeah I
get the vibe do you watch your own show
I do not because I shot it already and I
was sitting in that chair for a hour and
a half to then see eight minute pitch
I already suffered the hour and a half
yeah it's been 11 season 11 seasons yeah
do you feel like being on shark tank has
changed your brand and like your your
whole company in a way it's changed
everything he's saying my brand my whole
company the way that I perceived and
look to life you know I I went on the
show initially trying
get good deals because it was those 708
I had so many clothing brands and I was
only getting fish clothing brands can
you know people try to put every one of
us who listening and watching this in a
box yeah I wanted to get different brand
because when I would go to a big
retailer I can get a more real estate
not just clothing but I get electronics
I'll get plate wear or whatever the case
is so I was looking for really sharkus
deals but then we found out you know how
much the show inspired people and I
found out how I was learning from the
younger people and the older people who
are coming up and doing business in new
way so it's really educated me in a very
so many ways and now I'm known globally
for being a business person instead of
the they thought when I used to walk in
the doors I was gonna have baggy jeans
gold teeth and some great dancing so
when a pitch comes in that's clothing
focused it always seems like it's like
being put on you should take the deal
but more often than not you don't I
don't and now that makes sense why yeah
I usually hate it but but then let's
look at it let's look at being
open-minded what did I end up becoming
more successful in the only thing that I
didn't want to do box
right right so a lot of times when
where's power shifting sometimes we have
to dig into the inventory and what has
made us who we are sometimes sometimes
you have to have that move one theory
but sometimes you have to take inventory
yourself and say I'm really good here
yeah you know like I know this why why
do I always have to move on let me keep
a little bit of my time and energy in
this in what made me yeah I think what
people love about you most on the tank
is what you wear obviously cuz you're a
man about town definition of a man about
town do you have a stylist when it comes
to matching your handkerchief in your
time how do you uh how do you fair I do
this beautiful beautiful woman very
classy named Artemis she Styles all of
us though so I just happened to come in
with really great pieces and then say
can you sprinkle them a little yeah you
know Kevin comes in with his Undertaker
outfit all the damn time right Cuban we
got to wrestle him we got to hold him
down on the ground in the trailer to put
a suit on him cuz he comes in with a
Tony the Tiger shirt pancake batter on
it and we always see mark you got a
dressing
like I'm too rich I have I I determine
how other people dress I'm too rich
leave me alone the leaves that the
wrestling that's awesome that is so
great I have enjoyed talking I feel like
I could sit here for hours no totally
all my Shark Tank questions absolutely
love the tank we love you thank you to
the show and to you for everything
you've taught us about business you're a
female run business and everything we
know is from shark tank we're doing
pretty okay you could buy the book on
Amazon buy the book on our channels
absolutely hi Damon John follow you on
social media for any updates on the book
and just premium content you're put you
actually have one more question for you
what are your thoughts on tick tock I
love to god I'm trying to figure out how
they would put it in the ways that I
mean I love doing dad jokes one tick
tock so you know I do have some musical
things I'm trying to figure out my
actual voice one tick tock yeah you know
it has to be again authentic to who I am
yeah but like in terms of an investment
you see it maybe as being a long-term
form a long-term thing you know I don't
know I leave that up to this morning
Ungar generation I think it determined
it is but I think it should be I think
it would be because it scaled so quickly
yeah globally - yeah and globally of
course it's out of China but yeah okay
so the books available on Amazon follow
at shark did the shark team the shark
Damon on Instagram thank you so much for
being here
my sister's by the book available on
Amazon we'll be back with the rest of
the show so take a break go get a snack
or whatever we'll be back in five
dead and broken welcome back
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do age come
to town do-do-do-do-do welcome back to
the tank you guys wow I'm like dead I I
I like don't love having guests first
because I always like need to debrief
and maybe we need to see brief now
because that was like such a big deal no
sometimes it like having the s first so
that we can talk about it in the same
episode true that was so much fun I
literally I'm so obsessed with him and I
was just trying to maintain my cool but
I think I think we were quite
professional I think we were
professional I cannot believe that he
remembered us from the ha was like I
wasn't sure if he was just being nice or
like he actually did cuz he was citing
some some real details yeah yeah yeah I
might I'm dead yeah anyways that was
really exciting that was really exciting
ever go get his book I feel like every
single person who watches the show like
watches shark tank of course also
because every single person in the world
watches Shark Tank so I'm just like so
excited for all of us that we were just
in the presence of Daymond John and
unfortunately we do have to move on with
the show so we're going to have a lot to
discuss five we're gonna recap the
bachelor episode last night women tell
all
tons of news tons of gossip tons of
things we need to discuss so I just
think we should get right into it you
think it's time I mean it's 11:15 I do
think I think the definition of it being
time definitely so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and that's true but Daymond John
was just here you know we're talking
about how fly he is and we need to get
on his level and I think in order to do
that we can do so with the real real
where you can own iconic luxury items at
an unreal value with the real real the
leading reseller of authenticated luxury
consignment from top designers like
Louie Vuitton Gucci rolex cartier and
hundreds more up to ninety percent off
retail you could shop and consign
women's and men's luxury fashion and
street wear as well as fine jewelry
watch his art at home with new arrivals
coming in daily every item undergoes the
rail rails meticulous brand specific
authentication process overseen by a
hundred plus experts including luxury
brand authenticators gemologist sand her
ologist
you can shop luxury the sustainable way
at their newest location in Union Square
San Francisco you can also go online
download the app or visit one of their
original stores in Soho and Madison
Avenue in New York or West
would nla plus if you're looking to
consign some of your designer items you
can try out the rail rails white-glove
service for free and home pick up today
so whether you shop in store online or
on the app get 20% off select items with
promo code real that's the real real
calm promo code real for 20% off select
items thank you the real real let's
let's jump right into it love the real
real truly I just want to say I'm also
wearing my Rafi's today of course one
day too late one yes I'm wearing my
momís ok let's get right into it because
Northwest has taken Paris Fashion Week
by stormy Webster and it was everything
of the sort now we've got a little bit
of controversy and there was that - a
controversy attached to it which you
think just like a child performing is
pure but in these days it's not okay
well the performance itself if you
haven't seen it like you absolutely must
I don't know if I'm so moved by it one
because it's like just a child and it's
just like Shark Tank like anything they
do is perfect and honestly like to be a
kid and like perform on the stage like
that when you're not like a performer
she's not like Jojo see well it's really
scary i commended her bravery like not
getting nervous or she did a great job
yeah and she was so cute and she really
is just like so cutely talented we've
all seen her perform at her school which
I'm obsessed with that video and now
she's taking it to the main stage she
performed a song that turns out to be a
remix of the song by Zaza
so is she performed an easy season 8
fashion show yes with Sunday service
also they're performing there was she
the sole performer I believe she was the
sole performer line of of the show she
was the headliner but he had done Sunday
service in Paris yes so they're really
you know hitting every avenue every
Avenue I'm sorry as they say in Paris
every room so every room 57 North
performed afterwards they live streamed
it - that's how most people watched and
you can catch the video easy calm and
that's available on YouTube and
Instagram
yes but then afterwards an Instagram
account called red carpet girls posted
saying that in july 2019 zazz ah and her
dad went into the studio for the
ultimate experience to finally begin
making the music she wanted we take
pride in creativity and believe whether
a child's involved or an adult
creativity deserves respect and homage
what at Kim Kardashian and Kanye are
doing with their daughter with the
inspiration of Zaza and our family in
mind is okay we're not mad but they just
wanted some credit which Kim then posts
on Twitter Instagram and commented that
it was a remix of Zaza song and north
love Zaza and she hopes she liked the
remix whose Aza she is a little uh
performer but she's so she's so cute
she's so little and her sources like her
number-one fan
yeah of course the song is called um I
want what to call it I don't know uh I
won't do anything bad or something yeah
and that's what's playing while North is
you know she's hovering Ella P and
cheese made it her own a little bit but
it is as original song got it I mean I
guess I did assume that this was like a
song that Kanye and North wrote together
um so it is kind of like sad that the
South didn't get credit initially but
then I think like how do you give credit
when doing a cover song right and then
she took to Instagram came right after
and tagged
zaza and I made it right okay and also
Kim had said that this was kind of a
last-minute decision so there was no
intention good or bad going into it
having to like riff on Zaza song you
know I mean I just get why it's probably
frustrating like if this Instagram
account didn't post anything like would
they have credited her but I just don't
understand how you properly credit
someone when you're singing a cover of
their song yeah I guess I'm supposed to
know that it's a cover but this is not a
popular song enough that people wouldn't
know that it's not North's I did assume
that it was north so I see where the
frustration is but I don't know how you
do this correctly right but I think that
now 24 hours later has been done
correctly because now we're talking
about Zaza I love her song yeah I've got
a second my head and I think and
everyone wins what I didn't like about
this when I was reading the stories I
saw that Kim commented on the Instagram
posting right above Kim's comment was a
comment from Tinashe and she wrote North
West wishes or Northwest could never
which is like why are you talking [ __ ]
about a kid you're an adult yeah I guess
she has beef with the Kardashians
because of Ben Simmons which by the way
I have all the beef that you want but
like you're literally talking [ __ ] on to
public answer I'm about a child like
what are you doing yeah I was so proud
of North by the way she's so I think
cute and that I just I can't get over
the amount of bravery that takes like
first of all for anyone to perform on
like a global stage is a really big deal
but for a child like how did she not get
so nervous I haven't no idea and she
really like kept up like of course she
you know I'm nobody's perfect she had
her mistakes but I I
just was really impressed with the
bravery because to me that's like the
bravest thing you could do yeah and to
me I didn't even notice the fashions
like she absolutely she stole the show
it was a Northwest concert followed by a
Yeezy fashion show and I think we've
been wondering when North was you know
gonna step into the limelight and I just
think this is the beginning of my
beautiful journey for her yeah it's just
interesting like North could really be
anything she wants to be like I know she
was really into makeup for a while but
then like Kanye put the brakes on that
um and she could she could go into
fashion she could go into music she can
go into beauty and she's choosing music
she's following in her father's
footsteps she truly is her father's
daughter
yeah I think she's gonna do it although
I think it's just gonna be icon a mogul
yeah and chopper her in music fashion
beauty etc she's really like so grown
she's so iconic it's crazy yeah like
that I'm a grown woman and I'm just like
what's north wearing what's north media
what's north out - yeah I feel like
that's how Kim feels about her - you
know the way like Kim you still look at
Kylie and be like what are the youths
doing yeah she looks at north and is
like let's go and tick-tock well that
begs the question what happened to Mason
Disick stick talk we spoke about it
briefly when he did a chick talk with
David Roberge Kim and Kourtney and then
he was like thirst-trapping-- like doing
a closet tour of his house and then the
next day his tuktuk was completely gone
yeah well you think he got in trouble
from Kourtney I don't know maybe he
wasn't enjoying it maybe like all the
way maybe all the eyeballs it was just
too much pressure maybe he made a
private account instead and you don't
get your mom to take you to david dobrik
house for your tick-tock just to delete
it the next day yeah I don't know the
kids these days maybe they're being mean
to him maybe has a thick fog maybe you
know maybe he was being mean to him
though yeah me know he couldn't take the
heat oh that's that's actually very sad
yeah um
next up also a very sad story James
Lipton the host of inside the Actor's
Studio has died at the age of 93 Wow
yeah longtime TV writer and inside the
actress studio host James Lipton has
died he was 93 his death his peaceful
death was confirmed to TMZ on Monday
morning by his wife Kedah Chi Turner
quote there are so many James Lipton
stories but I'm sure he would like to be
remembered as someone who loved what he
did and had tremendous respect for all
the people he worked with Lipton who was
the dean emeritus of the Actors Studio
Drama School at Pace University retired
from the emmy-winning Inside the Actors
Studio in 2018 after hosting it for 24
years
I mean inside the actress to do I never
watch but I totally understood like the
severity and the prestige of what it
meant to be on it it's just so funny to
think that it was on the same network as
bad remember all's yeah it did seem like
I mean before Bravo is what it is now it
was like the top chef' like more like
emmy-nominated vibe now it's so much
better a Project Runway used to be like
Project what any Top Chef Inside the
Actors Studio and he really has changed
Bravo so much but and he wrote such nice
tweets about James Lipton saying he was
like the most wonderful guy when he
found out that Andy loved Diana Ross so
much he took him to a concert this is
like obviously sad it's always sad when
someone dies but again this is the thing
where it's like someone had a really
long accomplished life there I feel like
I'm at the age of 93 next to his Miley
like I feel like that's really all you
can ask for I in this lifetime and to go
out being so well-respected by so many
of your peers I mean I don't have that
no okay next story Carrie Underwood is
on the cover of women's health saying
that she ate as few as 800 calories a
day after American Idol she was she ate
as few as 800 calories a day after
American Idol that's so sad during her
time on the hit singing competition the
36 year old now would read message
boards critiquing her weight gain quote
I shouldn't care what other people think
about me she said in the issue new issue
of women's health adding that she'd been
living off quesadillas and pasta at the
time quote I was tired I kept buying
their clothes I knew I could be better
for myself and I let my haters be my
motivators when the show ended in May
2005 she decided she decided to start
counting calories while the group went
on the American Idols Live tour quote I
was sleeping better and I had more
energy for our grueling schedule she
continued and continued to push the diet
further until she was only eating about
800 calories a day I mean you know it's
so not funny but interesting is like you
think that in the last 10 years like
with social media like it's oh it's like
a new thing that people are being so
critiqued but like she's reading this on
message boards like this right really
before Twitter and Instagram like even
then like people were getting to her ya
know it's been it's been going on for so
long it's it's so sad and nobody's
immune to it yeah and right now I feel
like she is what we consider you know
the picture of health she has her
fitness clothing line she's those legs
she's so muscular she's so toned and
like she clearly makes Fitness a
priority and it just goes to show you
that you never know what people are
going through it never it doesn't come
easy for
anyone yeah and it doesn't it it doesn't
discriminate against anyone you know it
can like he can affect anyone and that's
something that I want to talk about
batcher would yeah it was a really
interesting episode and I like that they
took the last ten minutes to talk about
something a little more serious and I
love that Rachel Lindsay was there to do
it the one she was the only person who
really good yes I totally agree and now
we have a few more stories but I would
be so upset actually just [ __ ]
breezing through them
Chris Harrison said last night he would
be remiss if he didn't ask Victoria
about like something and I too would be
remiss if I didn't let everyone know
that today's episode is additionally
brought to you by legacy box legacy box
is an amazing subscription service that
I cannot believe not subscription
service I apologize is amazing company
that I cannot believe that I did not
come up with if you have old boxes of
video tapes photos collecting dust in
your closet or attic or if you've been
wanting to digitize your old photos and
videos but haven't known where to start
legacy box is shaping your future they
digitally preserve your family's legacy
so it can be passed down for generations
to come
it's the most genius thing ever you can
get a lifetime of old family memories
videotapes photos and more digitized to
a thumb drive a cloud download or a DVD
to share and enjoy for generations to
come
the process is so easy from start to
finish you go online purchase the box
that you need they send you a legacy box
kit so you fill it up with all your
media slap on the prepaid mailing label
and then just send it packs send it back
a few weeks later legacy box takes it
from there you'll get all your originals
back plus a perfectly preserved digital
copy ready to watch share and relive
they keep you informed throughout the
process with regular email updates over
700,000 families have trusted legacy box
and they've been in business over a
decade and this is an industry leader
and professionally digitized antiquated
media it is literally the best thing
ever we like grew up like video taping
ourselves watching Spice Girls and
singing and dancing to Spice Girls and
we've recently come across when we were
cleaning out our downstairs storage unit
like so many videos so many photos and
the photos are like cool to look out but
they're so dusty and then the videos
like you have to get literally like an
adapter yeah it just it's literally
impossible so I think that this is a
great company and it's such a good gift
for someone who's like into that really
sentimental kind of stuff it's an
amazing gift idea order your legacy box
so take advantage of legacy boxes sale
for a limited time take an unprecedented
60
off go to legacy box.com slash toast to
get your 60% off your order go to legacy
box.com slash toast to get 60% off your
order
save your time in memories go to legacy
box.com slash toast and save 60% love it
sign-on preserve your memories because
they're beautiful they they're worth
preserving
they are next story and her looks so
long it's crazy it's so crazy how long
it's good I just never thought I would
live to see the day where your hair was
longer than mine I know I do need a
haircut because it's really good trim at
the end so that and that way can grow
even faster
remember and you had a bob I know
sometimes I miss her not right now I'll
definitely go back to her later in my
life but raisi thing you did what I
liked I loved the Bob and I missed the
Bob life but what I don't miss is the
years of growing it out where like it
Lloyd a memorable no not even that it's
just like I didn't like the lengths
along the way I actually like growing
out my hair because I find new lengths
that I for the most part like no when I
look back at pictures of when i was like
in between Bob and now it is nothing of
the sort I hate being in between Bobby I
was also just like ugly and like not
catching a vibe you know maybe okay next
story is really sad but Tyler Cameron
has confirmed that his mother has passed
away he said today have been gained an
angel we will love and miss our mother
dearly she will live on through us and
through those that she has had an impact
on while we grieve we ask for two things
first to tell those you love that you
love them and second please let us take
this time to celebrate her life in
private thank you for all of your love
and support it's so sad oh my god and
when I saw this um I was scrolling
through her Instagram and she was just
like such a fan of The Bachelor she was
like so proud of her sons it's so so so
so heartbreaking so heartbreaking um I
didn't expect him to put out a statement
like so fast yeah because I feel like
this must be so devastating the last
thing he's saying him out is like what
do I tell the public because he's not a
traditional celebrity he's been it you
know but he doesn't act like a famous
person less than a year so like he
doesn't need to think in this way but I
know there was a lot of speculation
about it and so I'm sure he just wanted
to second the record I'm sure honestly
he's just so busy he like didn't post
this like someone else did I don't know
the pictures really personally came from
him yeah hammer under the caption yeah
anyways I feel like all
we can give him right now in this
respect and and in our thoughts and our
thoughts yeah yeah grief is a [ __ ]
mm-hmm okay
fifth and final story little comedy news
that maybe very interest I know the
story and I think it's fantastic
Netflix is launching a major la comedy
festival this spring Netflix is going
big or going home whether that means its
original proba programming slate awards
campaigns or subscriber base now the
streamer is applying the principle to an
old-school format the comedy festival
writes the LA Times on Monday the
company announced Netflix is a joke
Netflix is a joke fest with more than
100 performances from some of comedies
biggest names across 20 plus la venues
and culminating in a Hall of Fame
tribute to for late legends George
Carlin Richard Pryor Joan Rivers and
Robin Williams rivers finally getting
the respect she deserves
finally like to see it the lineup
includes Dave Chappelle David Letterman
Amy Schumer Ali Wong Jerry Seinfeld
Chris Rock Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin
Jamie Foxx Sarah Silverman Kevin Hart
Billy crystal will be Goldberg ken Jeong
and Martin Lawrence Wow I mean literally
I'm going because I need to see Dave
Chappelle like the fact that he did
immediately chose in New York and we
never went looks like what's wrong with
us was before we were woke to the genius
headed Steve Chappelle I think this is
so brilliant like first of all I think
Netflix has really like carved out of
space and themselves to be taken really
seriously when it comes to comedy mostly
because they just pay more than anyone
and then everyone wants to be on Netflix
and they have the biggest subscriber
base like if you're comedies on Netflix
you're gonna open yourself up to an
audience that never would have known you
before um and I think first of all this
is so cool for like a streaming service
to now take something too IRL it's like
never been done like you it's the
opposite so yeah I think it's genius I
think they have like top-tier talent
because they pay people like Jerry
Seinfeld and Dave Chappelle 60 million
dollars to do a special and I'm sure
that 60 million dollars included this
yeah and who wouldn't want it now
Netflix has made themselves such a name
and comedy like who wouldn't want to be
a part of it I think it's amazing yeah
they're so cool oh wow other headliners
will include bill burr Pete Davidson
Chelsea Handler Jenny slate Whitney
Cummings Marlon Wayans
iliza shlesinger and Michelle wolf so
it's really like everyone who's ever
been on Netflix and also 11 of the live
shows will be available to stream on
at a later date which is genius it's
just like synergy content on content on
container to vertical entry degree
horizontal speaking of I actually saw
some very sad business today what that
Jack well with a little sad Jack Welsh
the former head of GE who was an I who
was an icon for Jack Donaghy huh his
passed away oh so sad I didn't know Jack
Donaghy was loosely based off of a real
person you know Jack Donaghy looked up
to Jack Welch who was a real person oh
he was like the head of GE and he turned
it into microwave a four billion dollar
coming to a four hundred billion dollar
company got it and he's passed away so
very sad wishes well wishes back to this
Netflix thing when I saw it I thought it
was so genius and it's like so rare that
a company does something right you know
what I mean I feel like we're always
like making fun of these lame decisions
that these kind of like old-school media
companies put out but Netflix is just on
the money yeah this is this is pretty
brilliant I hope it's the beginning of
you know many comedy festivals maybe
even those and then you know what and
then it goes on Netflix to watch and
sometimes the only thing better than
going to a music festival is watching
the live stream I couldn't agree more
not even a live stream an edited version
afterwards like there's absolutely
nothing in this world I love more than a
concert DVD and I fell in love with
concert DVDs when I bought the Taylor's
head Speak Now at RadioShack literally
ten years ago and actually so funny that
you brought that I just want to say like
I'm crazy Miley Cyrus did it first I'm
pretty sure she invented the concert DVD
because the first one that I remember in
my lifetime was the best of both worlds
tour and then Jonas Brothers did in then
Taylor Swift in it and I'm like it was
in my heart period where people were
putting it in theaters yes but like
maybe I just didn't like come alive
until that time it was totally Miley
Cyrus - Miley Cyrus invented the concert
TBD okay but she did it because of my
mind tell her no no but Taylor's was
after Miley so I'm hearing the DVD Miley
Cyrus was in theaters I'm very sure that
Miley didn't invent it but like it to
you according to me she did well then I
also got me thinking that's so funny
that this came up on the show today
because I was thinking this morning when
I was doing my makeup that I wanted to
bring this up on the show is we were
told a really long time ago that Ben
Platts show at Radio City Music Hall was
being filmed for a Netflix special and
it's been a long time oh I don't even
remember hearing that that sounds too
good to be true you think no no I'm like
100% sure that it was true
oh I hope so but now you're gonna have
my hopes up and maybe it's just like
it's not his time yet and so maybe
they'll start doing that with like lots
of different people and then turn it
into a music festival I would love that
me too and it's all they always do it
with people like who are already in the
Netflix family like he was with the
politician so I don't know who's another
Swift
Taylor Swift Beyonce Beyonce mm-hmm I'm
telling you like they're what they did
with comedy I think they're starting to
do with music Wow we get like a Sunday
service they'll be sick that would be
everything of the sort yeah Wow
okay well those were the past five
stories that you needed to know but
mostly what everyone's talking about
this morning is last night's episode of
The Bachelor and women tell all
they did something strange but
interesting and I understand because
they had observed it a rose ceremony
okay I can't
I shan't I went you can't and you most
certainly shan't because I have
something to say Jackie my god we're
gonna recap The Bachelor of course but
not without telling you that today's
episode is also brought to you by
Missouri what if I told you you can wear
fine jewelry every day without it
costing a fortune or waiting for a
hand-me-down from Grandma with Missouri
you get ethically sourced fine jewelry
without having to choose between
high-quality and fair prices they drop
new pieces every Monday all versatile
enough to be styled with anything you
own from day to night be on the lookout
each week for fresh and exciting pieces
sometimes under 150 dollars we're
talking 14 carat solid gold staples that
don't wear out or scratch easily
sterling silver pearls and even diamonds
Missouri is all about high quality but
low maintenance because fine jewelry is
precious just like Theo but you don't
have to be Precious about it I have been
wearing Majoris since before they
started sponsoring the show and I found
out about them because Lauren Elizabeth
like when I first started following her
years ago did a collab with them and
that's why I first found out about the
brand and I've been shopping there a
while and now we have a code which is so
exciting full circle for the TNN family
head to Missouri
Maj you are i.com slash toast or use the
code toast at checkout for 10% off your
first order that's missouri mej URI
dot-com slash toasts for 10% off your
first order check it out we think you
really like it if you want to live
snatch maybe end up on The Bachelor
that's what you need to do women so well
yes as I nine get precious gem I was
like almost positive that it was the
women tell all but then they went into
the rose ceremony I'm like oh maybe
we'll Mintel all's next week well I'm
actually overall really glad that they
did it this way
cuz the dog was eliminated we got to
hear from her I think she changed so
many hearts in minds I am myself
included do I stand Victoria F well I've
always like had a really soft spot in my
heart for her because I just happen to
think she's literally the most beautiful
girl to ever grace the planet and people
also tell me that I look like her and
then I was glad that we got to see her
on after the final rose and there's a
lot that she needs to speak on mom
because so much has come out after the
show like about her and around her I was
a little disappointed that they didn't
ask her about like the major controversy
that she went through which was the
white lives matter like Cosmo magazine
not posting her cover like there was a
lot there and I think it was shocking
that they didn't bring it up yeah I
wonder if they did bring it up and then
cut it out maybe they just like didn't
make the final cut but then also when
you think about it whenever someone goes
through a really major controversy and
they don't win they never really address
it you know like garroted garroted but
because he won and I think he needed to
like change some minds about him but
there's been so many times where we hear
something from whether it's reality
Steve or you know something comes up and
someone doesn't address it like even
that time with Jenna Cooper and you know
she looks like cheating on and she got
engaged Jordan it just they just never
addressed it yeah I mean to me it was
just like not avoidable but they just
went up and avoided it so whatever but
Jeannie or maybe they thought that her
statement was submission but then they
did speak on something we saw on-screen
which they had to address was that
random girl going up to Peter and
telling her that telling him that
Victoria has like broken up multiple
couples and it's responsible for the
breakdown of four marriages or whatever
so she answered it very straightforward
and just said no that's not true I mean
we have no way of knowing whether that's
true I think that you know with social
media we will eventually find out if
this is true or not if she really did
break up a marriage I think there's a
wife you know crafting a tweet a video
with a certain reaction with some
receipts about how Victoria f ruined her
relationship so I think that if she's
lying she will be called out in due time
I don't think she would just lie on
national television like that and I
think so like boldwood yeah I think that
if it were semi true maybe she had a
relationship with a married person she
could say it wasn't like that I did date
someone who was separated like the
instance that this person was referring
to has to do with my ex boy
who was married at the time like right
right so she just said flat out no with
no extra details right so I think it
would be very brazen for her to just lie
about that considering you know the
truth always comes out everything that's
dark comes to light and I think she did
a really good job of expressing why she
was so difficult on the show yeah and
honestly I have no choice but to respect
someone who's self-aware and she says I
look back on those conversations and
like see how Peter was like trying so
hard with me and I was giving him
nothing to work with like someone who
goes back watches himself and has some
sort of awareness to their actions like
I have no choice but to respect that
yeah and I think that's why even though
sometimes women tell all can be painful
and it's just an audition for bachelor
in paradise and people are being thirsty
it is a time when people who are
portrayed as villainous on their season
really do get to speak for themselves
redeem themselves like I remember Olivia
creedy's women tell all was really
transformative for the way that I felt
about her and I do think that Victoria
I've had a really good night after
having a really terrible few weeks and
to me she was never really the villain
of the season because she never did or
said anything it's just like what we
knew about her offline yeah to me like
the villains were all sitting in the
audience like I honestly think that
Victoria P is the worst I think that
McKenna is the worst and I think that
Sydney's the worst oh I like Sydney so
much she's right fifty percent of the
time like she stands and defends
Victoria payment she shouldn't because
Victoria P so wrong and in the Alaia
situation she was so wrong but in the
Tammy situation she was so right so
sometimes I was loving what she was
saying and sometimes I was not
yeah it's sometimes like Tammy I was so
on her side like when she was talking
about my Kenna first um she's so right
and for my Kenna - I've been like the
star last night when she was really like
nothing of the sort
on her season I don't even mean that in
like such a negative way I just mean
like she was just a random another girl
who's coming here to be a blogger like
she wasn't here nor there
and it's she's sitting next to Kelsey to
me because they're really good friends
know and it's also because Kelly and
Natasha weren't invited and that's what
was missing number five and number six
like those are the real girls who we got
to know to me the absolute star of women
tell him the only person who was
spitting [ __ ] facts was Savannah
literally just being out here saying
maybe the unpopular thing like when
everyone was but just being so mean to
Alya like they never had any
creet evidence or things that they
didn't like about a liar other than the
fact that she lit up when she was on
camera which is what you [ __ ] do what
do you want a slob on TV like before we
go live on this show we're like this yes
and then vouching and just we talk very
minute own and then the show comes on we
sit up straight we raise our octave and
we give you a show to me everything that
happened with Alya last night even
confirmed for me even more that she did
absolutely nothing wrong the girls like
just did it like her and I get that you
have like a gut feeling about someone
but that's not enough to start a fight
with them and like turn a lot of people
on I'd like to talk about them with
Peter I totally agree and you know what
app by last night I was like who are we
even talking about like the Elias stuff
is so last year yeah I just it's not
it's not interesting to me at all
because it was confusing and they never
gave us the real details even Chris
Harrison's calling the fight confusing
but like you're the one your people are
the ones who like put this fight out
there and yet the confusion that it was
I just like on so many instances Chris
Harrison is like you know calls out the
production but it's like you're the
production totally I fell in love even
more is Kelsey last night I just and I
know that everyone thinks it's so weird
that every time she talks she cries like
there's just people like that and I
didn't really feel like this like the
connection between her and Ashley I can
any like to me they're so different so
different to me Kelsey cries about the
way she feels about Peter and the way
she describes how Peter totally accept
her even though like someone could
perceive her as crazy like that's how I
felt watching like I think he's so
wholeheartedly accepted her for who she
was and like never made her feel weird
for being emotional and that was great
but when Ashley I can Eddie was on I
just didn't get the vibe that she was
crying because of like the way she felt
about Chris or like I just like she was
crying just to cry you Ashley
yeah it was it was a weird stretch like
I don't get when they do stuff like that
she to me doesn't remind me of Ashley I
whatsoever
II knew that um until I guess because
they both cry like there's a million
different reasons to cry yeah and I just
loved Kelsey like I love that she's so
herself like people gave her so much
[ __ ] over the season and she could have
come on women tell all and like been
different and like acted how people
wanted her to but she was just the same
person she was on TV yeah and she took
accountability for letting her emotions
get the best of her but she's also
justified here in emotions like
sometimes when you have an emotional
reaction like you absolutely cannot
control how you feel like it that's what
an emotion is and she said
I was entitled to how I felt but I
definitely overreacted again we have no
choice but to respect someone who can
point out their own flaws like yeah and
I do wish they'd just gotten to the
bottom of why that bottle of Dom was
important to her because I do think
there's a story there yeah and I would
have liked to hear it because like it's
not your average bottle of Dom agreed
there was definitely more like she got
it for graduation or something yeah
then Victoria went up and sat with Chris
and Peter right mm-hmm
I think that it's just so weird like to
be honest when all the girls were
talking to him at the end they were all
just like being thirsty like using it
does anyone anything they want to talk
to Peter like yeah I want to be on
paradise let me ask her diamond question
um but it really did seem like they all
had respect for Peter and they didn't
feel like slighted by him and even
though I think he handled the entire
season so poorly and really from a
viewer standpoint was frustrated with
his indecisiveness and a lot of the
decisions that he made it seems like
none of the girls feel like they were
wronged by him you know no but they're
also like if anything I feel like he led
so many girls on the season and medias
because Kelly and Natasha weren't there
to call him out everyone else was like
it's okay Peter will keep your secret we
need to know why I mean I I've heard
that people say that Kelly was in breach
of her contract because she spoke a lot
about her edit but Natasha like what the
[ __ ] I saw something in toasters or
snatchler nation a photo of Kelly on her
Instagram serene it might have been
flipped but in like if it wasn't it
looks like she has a ring on her finger
oh look she met someone and got engaged
maybe that would make way more sense to
me than she talked about her edit to
mine where she comes back she comes o
and gets engaged to Peter hell to the no
no oh so now that Hannah and Madison are
the final two go bring her back to us
the modeling they keep teasing that
[ __ ] thing with him I was crying and
I can't yeah
I think and I think I heard this on the
snatch or last night I listened to it
make sure to check it out they had some
audio issues but if you don't have
misophonia which i don't it's fine to
listen to i got through the whole thing
but if you do have misophonia do not
listen to it
snatchler says that she thinks that
peter wants to end up with Madison but
Madison can't do it they doesn't choose
anyone but then in this time he's been
like courting Madison and maybe he'll
propose
to her after the final rose that's a
good that's a good theory yeah I just
hope that in the end of this like Hannah
Brown doesn't come back like when Chris
Brown pulls him over when he's about to
propose proud Chris Harrison
pulls Peter over it's like we just found
something out and if it's like Hannah's
here I'm literally gonna jump off a
cliff like I just can't I think what
he's gonna say is Maddie left yeah but
even if you proposed her she thinks that
she can't do it because you [ __ ] two
other girls last night I hope that's not
it I wanted to make Realty like Madison
is married to someone else like yeah and
has a boyfriend one of the girls is
pregnant yeah crazy
that would be condoms and they have to I
think that they don't know I'm pretty
sure I read somewhere that they don't
provide condoms well I mean I think it's
safe to assume that most of the girls
are on birth control but still you can't
just assume that no I don't it's not
because they assume one way or the other
I think I don't know why they wouldn't
have condoms there that's an interesting
question I've never asked anyone who's
been in a fantasy suite that I maybe I'm
gonna text Raven gates yeah even though
she famously admitted on this show that
she'd never had sex with Nick file but
she would have seen a bowl of cotton she
would have known if there was protection
they were around yeah yeah Wow crazy but
easy Maddie got the Rose had accepted it
and he gave her such a big hug and they
cut to Hannah and who had tears in her
eyes like I actually felt really bad for
her yeah that was like a pathetic moment
cuz she knows like she most likely did
not have sex with Peter I'm getting that
vibe and so at that point she knows that
it's not her yeah also back to women
tell all these women are obviously
auditioning for paradise and it's gonna
be a really interesting season of
paradise because Claire is gonna have
older men older than her and younger
than her but definitely men authority is
skew older whereas these girls are like
23 average um you know to maybe a kinda
em needs a 40 year old yeah also
bachelor and paradise always is
inherently flawed because the men who
come off the Bachelorette the best ones
are always waiting to see if they'll be
the bachelor so they don't go on
paradise they're now famous and they're
25 years old they just want like [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the DM just get like the weird
thirsty guys and but we also have the
best girls like Hannah and we'll
probably neon paradise cuz I don't think
she wins and then there's like no one
for her to match up with cuz the
runner-up of Bachelorette doesn't go on
paradise so maybe if ya older guys who
are just more mature maybe it'll make
power real matches yeah I have um this
is the first season since Ben
the season that I haven't known the
ending and I think that's either because
most people know this Steve hasn't I
think that I think it's because it
hasn't happened yet because I think it
will happen on after the final rose
maybe Peter trying to get Madison back
or something like that so I'm like
enjoying it I'm really I'm enjoying it
as well part of me just like is dying to
know but part of me is um he's okay with
it I just feel like I'm scared that it's
gonna be a nothing burger you know yeah
where it's like something it's I've been
like hyping it up for this big huge
thing that no one can figure out but I
feel like it's actually gonna be just
like uh it didn't work wah wah wah wah
exactly then Rachel Lindsay came on to
talk about bullying in bachelor nation
and at first I was like had such a pit
because I was like oh my god I've been
calling my kind of nothing of the sort
like I'm the bully no um then she
provided some of the context and the
content that these girls have been
received and I think by the way the most
important distinction that they made is
like there's a difference between
criticism and hate and you can be
critical of a show and like joke about
people saying dumb things but that's
wholly different than telling someone to
kill themselves a hundred percent I
can't believe that there are people out
there who send messages like I mean I I
believe it like we get crazy messages
too but like what kind of person and the
biggest losers first of all second of
all I like whenever I do get something
really awful it's always from an older
woman which is really weird and sad and
what I like I'm I mean I obviously like
to the segment but like part of me
really really [ __ ] wished that they
put the people's names oh agree and I
know that it's a liability because then
that person becomes a target and then
ABC is responsible for all the hate that
this person gets but there's no
accountability when it comes to stuff
like that and if you saw your name
Claudia ashtray sent to Sydney to go
kill herself I would hide under a rock
and never do again I would be mortified
there it scares people and not having
that accountability without the people's
names like obviously was still really
powerful but it could have really been
life-changing yeah I also have to
imagine people don't use their real
accounts to send these things sometimes
it would be surprised they use a finsih
and if it that's the case then it
wouldn't even matter if we saw their
handles or not but yeah there's a handle
attached I do think people should be
publicly shamed for being and I want
your picture up there yeah actually the
animals don't even have that much hate
being just the scum of the earth if
you're gonna tease someone for the way
that they look I mean you have to be
perfect looking oh right of course but
also like for someone to kill themselves
because you don't like the way that they
acted on a reality TV show dramatic
change the channel yeah it's a little
dramatic Sally
it's so crazy I felt so bad for the
girls I do think that with every season
it gets worse and worse like the online
bullying and snatcher said this too but
she's like they get so much out of the
show we know they become famous and they
get sponsors in blah blah blah but I
think that they earn every single
foreign dollar because they go through
so much they put up with so much it
takes a really strong person to go on
that show and I like as much as we have
issues with the girls on the show like I
have so much respect for them agreed I
mean it's it looks fun but it ain't easy
it has its moments but yeah and I feel
like this is now a theme happening like
in reality television especially with
like what happened to Caroline Flack and
I feel like people are taking it way too
far
and we all like it needs to be reeled in
yeah and I think the only way to enact
real change is to like hold people
accountable like it should be a crime
mm-hmm like I mean I hate hate speech or
hate acts of hate hate crimes are a
crime yeah so if you're sending someone
a message calling in the N word like I
think that I should be able to get your
IP address and go to your house and
arrest you we're telling someone to go
kill themselves like that happens like
in school bullying terrible it has to I
don't know how it changes but I do think
like segments like last night are really
powerful and like them addressing it on
such a national stage I think if you're
someone who ever sent a message like
that like you should be absolutely
mortified yeah and just like and I think
enough to realize like oh my god the
bachelors like wow what I did was really
your idea for a TV show is now more
pertinent than ever trolled a spin-off
of catfish where we go to people's
houses who write messages we find their
IP addresses and we show them and be
like hi is this your mom yeah she called
me that she called me big fat cow Jo not
even that she goes want me to kill
myself
yeah that's your daughter we need the
show yeah okay anything else before we
wrap up um no I think that's it next
week is a two night finale yay we have
tons of guests for the rest of the week
actually every
show this week we have another gas to
make sure you're following us on
Instagram we'll be announcing tomorrow's
guest tonight and I think you guys are
gonna freak the [ __ ] out like for real
like I think so too
it's really really a bet it's gonna be a
big week um can't wait thanks so much
for listening to the money test Maleny
morning sure where you live might at the
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
youtube so if watching us anew please
please subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast second read podcast we found so
it's about fighting stitcher public
video I arena cashbox oh the places
where ever you listen to podcast find us
some when he tells to hi leave a review
maybe subscribe maybe or 5-star comment
about how beautiful sending it's Mario I
don't know just a suggestion thank you
so much of an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow bye